I don't think so i think i mean our
industry has seen a lot of consolidation
over the over the years region up look
at miss Anne's relationship with Renault
which has been a fantastic alliance that
we've had here and it's just further
evidence of more more strategic
alliances mergers acquisitions and
partnerships so from my perspective it
doesn't really change a lot we'll have
to see how it plays out but it's just a
bit of theme of more consolidation but
if PSA reduces its commitment to
Vauxhall here in the UK potentially that
opens the door for you to sell more cars
in the UK I cannot comment on on sukkah
better I'm not understanding what their
plans are but up honestly I believe it
it doesn't really change the
competitiveness will still face a voxel
business a PSA business and will be
challenging alongside them you've just
announced that London is going to be the
first European city where you test
self-driving vehicles it's not a result
of the meeting that Carlos gone had with
number ten Downing Street last October
it's more of a reflection on on the
commitment we have in the UK we have a
obviously we design in paddington we
engineering cranfield and we obviously
have a big manufacturing plant in London
most of our investment in Europe is is
in the UK and also the UK government
have provided the right environment to
named last two to test now you'll call
me Colin lover told MPs last week that
if the UK left you without some sort of
trade deal if we had to fall back on WTO
rules i think the exact words he use
with this would change the business
circumstances is that something that
would then cause you to review your UK
investments no no not at all I mean
Colin was reacting to one very specific
question nothing has changed a position
is the same as it was at the end of the
summer we have made a commitment in the
UK we're bringing the new cash guy will
bring an extra from Japan to the UK
which shows our commitment to our
business in Sunderland and we have a
discussion with the government is very
transparent the government have made a
commitment that they would negotiate a
position where we will not be
disadvantaged not just this and our
industry as a whole so we take that at
face value and we're managing our
business
in that way and yet the Prime Minister
has said the UK is going to leave the
single market that doesn't represent a
change of circumstances we work on a
long-term basis we don't work on
short-term cycles so we made a
commitment I will understand what what
what comes out from the negotiations all
I can say is the UK government have been
very clear but they wish to negotiate
position that does not undermine at all
the the interest of the automotive
industry in the UK and we take that at
face value we trust them and we hope
that will come through looking at the UK
market right now obviously new car sales
have been very very strong for a number
of years now there's a lot of evidence
that wages are going to start falling
below inflation do you have any concerns
about what that's going to do for the
ability of customers to buy your cars in
the near future I think the UK market is
is quite buoyant I think Europe is all
we expect to see continued growth we saw
strong growth last year we expect that
grow to Kadir maybe not the same level
but strong growth into into 17 the
underlying consumer confidence in our
opinion and order statistics we see as
we see you know continued demand growth
in in the UK we don't see any any course
of concern of any contraction